11-8-4, 23
TO THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Drew: THE SAN JOSE SHARKS DO
AND THE HALL OF FAMER LARRY
ROBINSON AND JAY
WATCHED BY
SEASON FORE INURE
LIFE.
>> Drew: MANY.
MRE EASY THING TO
SAY, BUT WHEREM NOT SURE
HERE'S MEIER AGAIN
THE FINAL HA
HERE'S KOPITAR, AND HE SCORES!YE
KOPITAR.
IT
THAT'SO EARL,
BUT YOU CAN'T WALK U
MAATTA
MAATTAHERE
WATCH NUMBER 88 FOR TH THIS LINE
NOW.
HE STARTED THE GAME UP WIT
>> Drew:
KUN D
CUT DOWN BY MEGNA.
SHARKS CLEAR IT.
I WOULDN'T MISS IT
WOULD YOU? AS HE PUT IT
RIGHT ON THE STICKW DOUGHTY WITH
TRAFFIC IN FRONT
JAMES REIMER FINDS IA LATE GOALE
FIRST PERIOD
SHARKS WANT TOHARK TANK AS
TIMO MEIER BECOMES THE FIRST SR.
THANK YOU VERYNE THING YOU PREAS
A COACH IS GOOD HABITS, GUYS,
DOUGHTY.
FIRES, SETN'T IT
>> Drew: I WAS GOING TO SAY
THAT.
>> Randy: THAT'S BLOCKED